-I want to start you're
a national security reporter,
I think oftentimes when we see
those of your profession
on television
shows or in films,
it seems very fast paced,
very cinematic job.
Is that true in real life?
-So usually when you're
in the movies watching
national security films,
things like that,
there's this section
in the middle that's,
you know, this montage of
the reporter like on the phone
or digging through documents
and things like that,
like entirely unfilmable stuff.
That's where I live.
I'm the montage.
-You're just in the montage.
-That's right.
-No, actually exciting scenes,
but tiny moments
that have cut together
to music look interesting.
-Yeah.
Like, if you were lucky,
you stay in the montage.
Other times you're like
sweeping on the floor
and, you know, makeshift bases
in Iraq and Afghanistan
in the middle of the morning
waiting for a flight
out somewhere.
-So this came out.
The timing of this
was I don't know if you were
what you would call the time--
but came out two days before
Kabul fell to the Taliban.
It does seem like
one of the risks here
is looking at that tiny snapshot
of the withdrawal
of American troops
when we have this sort of
20 year war in this country.
What is your take insofar
as what happened in the days
after your book was published?
-So obviously this is a human
disaster, first and foremost.
And before any of us
get up on our soap boxes,
that's the most important thing
to recognize.
This has real impact
on real people's lives.
What I had a little bit
of trouble
with watching a lot
of the coverage of it
is someone who, you know,
not, you know,
as much as perhaps
some of my colleagues,
but has been to Afghanistan
and reported from there.
It was treated as if the end
of this phase of the war
was divorced from the 20 years
that came before it
and from being there
and reporting on it throughout.
It has been very clear
for a very long time
that the best time to leave
Afghanistan is always yesterday.
The second best time
is always today
and the worst time
is always tomorrow.
And that's what we saw.
The accumulation of all of
this rot and failure
and deceit, ultimately,
became what we saw on television
through this searing experience.
-So there were hearings today,
and we saw senators
from both sides of the aisle
questioned military leadership.
And, you know,
because this was 20 years,
you had a situation
where both parties
have a great deal of blame
in regards to how this went.
Did you feel like both parties
were trying to set
their own narratives
in their questions today?
What was your takeaway?
-Yeah, very much so.
One of the things
that I deal with in the book
is the interplay
between Democrats,
Republicans
and the security services,
and we really saw sort of
three phases of delusions
from each of them from the
Republicans today in testimony.
We saw this fixation
as has happened
throughout the War on Terror,
on a conditions-based withdrawal
and constantly attacking the
guests who were there to testify
from the military in the
Pentagon about that.
When in fact,
this was never going to be
a conditions-based withdrawal
because the agreement
that former President Trump
made with the Taliban stipulated
that as the end of the war.
Without looking
at that agreement,
you can't really understand
everything that came after.
Similarly, from
the Democratic perspective,
you had this delusion.
Tim Kaine mentioned it
that America is turning a page
on the forever war,
that we're no longer
going to be constantly at war,
and that is
just simply untrue.
Not only does the United States
keep 2500 troops in Iraq,
we just bombed Somalia,
we just bombed Syria.
Without rolling back all of the
operations of the War on Terror,
it is entirely deceitful
to describe the U.S.
as no longer being at war.
And then from the military side,
we saw a delusion
that we've seen
not just throughout
the Afghanistan war,
but throughout the wars
in general,
which is that the generals
who were testifying talked about
how last fall
they were recommending.
And this January, we're
recommending a residual force
to stay in Afghanistan.
Well, the trouble with that is
there was this agreement
with the Taliban
to keep U.S. forces
in Afghanistan
would have been violating
the most important aspect
of that agreement
for a government
that the United States could
not sustain and in violated --
in violation
of that agreement,
the Taliban would have made
a withdrawal from Afghanistan,
even a drawdown of it happening,
one that would occur under fire,
putting everyone, including
U.S. service members
and Afghan civilians at far
greater risk, and for what?
None of them were even inclined
to articulate
how keeping
a residual force in Afghanistan
would have done anything other
than keep the U.S. at best,
perhaps away from the precipice
of the disaster that we've seen.
And that has been a consistent
feature of the War on Terror
for most of
the last 20 years.
-I want to get to former
President Trump,
but you also talk about
former President Obama's
missed opportunity
after the assassination
of Osama bin Laden.
Where do you feel
like his missteps were?
-So first, it's Obama who really
makes the forever wars forever,
by entrenching them
in a less conspicuous,
less ground war
intensive campaign
that still remains
as global,
in fact, expands
to more battlefields
than it was under
the Bush administration.
Without any plausible theory
of how this knits up
into anything
that can be successful.
The measurement
of the War on Terror,
as it became less conspicuous
and more technocratic,
was that it continue
to be waged,
not that it be won
or successfully concluded.
The best time that anyone was
ever going to have to say here
is a natural point at which
the job the United States
set out to do after 9-11
is completed is in May 2011
with the assassination
of Osama bin Laden.
Instead, Obama and his deputy
for counterterrorism,
John Brennan,
who goes on to be a CIA director
and presides over a tremendous
amount of the drone war
that Obama starts,
is to say that this is
one milestone among many
and the job of the war
on terror,
although now it's no longer
called that continues.
And at that point,
we're unmoored from any real way
that makes any kind of sense
of concluding this.
We have been in that position
in the War on Terror longer
than before the United States
killed Osama bin Laden.
-You talk about how this
War on Terror,
the basically American
foreign policy
after 9/11 sort
of planted the seeds
that lead to Donald Trump.
What is what are those seeds
and how do they take root?
-Yeah. So 9/11
and the U.S. response to it
is this doorway
into the ugliest,
the most nativist aspects
of American history.
It's been a lot of talk
about how united America
was after nine 11.
In fact, it was marshaled
by political elites,
primarily in
the Republican Party,
but with the quick acquiescence
of the Democratic Party
against a definably
nonwhite enemy
that is both at home and abroad
and the apparatus of repression
that gets created
and gets expanded,
all of which takes the form
of loosening restraints,
legal restraints,
cultural restraints,
bureaucratic restraints
against surveillance,
against brutality like torture,
against indefinite detention,
against watch lists
that you can't ever get off.
All of that becomes entrenched,
institutionalized
and marshaled against this enemy
that the politics of it have
as an internal foe
that you're not really --
if you're, you know, frankly,
a white American able to trust
all of that is marshaled against
our Muslim-American neighbors.
And once that is unleashed,
once that is normalized,
once that is sustained,
once that's shown
that the political system
will accommodate
that kind of repression
against this definably
nonwhite internal enemy
that spreads like wildfire.
The War on Terror
isn't the only reason
that Donald Trump
becomes president,
but the War on Terror
is a pathway to power
under conditions of national
patriotic emergency
that allows all of that
other racism and nativism
to unite under
this rubric of emergency.
-I want to end on something
a little bit more upbeat,
which is you were going
to be writing a DC comic.
This is very exciting.
I love when people
from a world like yours
take that knowledge
and that experience
and bring it into
the comic book world.
And I have to say
it's a pretty good match.
-What are you writing?
-Well, thanks very much.
Really pleased to announce it
on your show.
I'm going to be writing
a Suicide Squad comic for DC
with my friend Evan Narcisse,
who wrote an amazing book
for Marvel,
"Rise of the Black Panther."
We're going to be taking
on a character, Amanda Waller,
who viewers of this show
may know
as the Viola Davis character
in the movies.
She is the big intelligence
figure in the DC Universe,
a character I absolutely love.
And next year,
if you're wondering,
you know, how does
this guy's critique work,
perhaps in a superhero universe?
-Right.
-We'll be answering
that question for you.
-Alright. But I do think people
should read this one first
and then enjoy
the comic book as a treat.
Thank you so much
for being here.
It's a wonderful book,
and I really appreciate
you spending time with us,
"Reign of Terror" is out now.